hey what's up lasagna leads here and I
am currently in Singapore with my wife
Amanda Lietz and we've just been a lot
exploring honestly this place is just
the best but I wanted to do a shout out
because I've noticed recently there's
been like an influx of new subscribers
and that is thanks to Patricia bright so
many people have been commenting saying
I'm here from producer bride Patricia
price sent me anyone who doesn't know
who Patricia Brite is definitely need to
check out her channel and also check out
the video that I did with her quite
recently I'll leave a link in the
description I am here with the family
because could you introduce me to
Patricia I did say if it wasn't for this
lady here my wife Amanda
I wouldn't know who Patricia is I'm
gonna be doing another video with
Patricia next year she's interviewing me
on her new finance channel talking about
property investments and Finance noir
things business on this video I wanted
to talk a little bit about
collaborations and joint ventures see so
many people come to me and they say Sam
I've got a problem so they've got this
problem I got that problem I haven't got
the finance I can't been a mortgage or I
can't find deals I haven't got time
listen listen listen
very simple rather than focusing on what
you haven't got it's very easy to say
what you haven't got you need to go out
what you have got what you have got
going for you I mean you might have
money but just haven't haven't got any
deals or
haven't got time or you might have time
and no money or you might be able to get
a mortgage you might have networks you
might have knowledge you know so focus
on what you have got and then once
you've done that then you can attract a
who a joint venture partner I mean
honestly if it wasn't for joint venture
partners in business I would be flat
broke I'd have no properties I'd have no
money
I wouldn't be able to afford I'm just
looking to do you man my goodness that
is something else but listen how am I
able to live the life I have is all
because the joint ventures my very first
house that I bought I put it in someone
else's name because I was tuned to gonna
mortgage my second house that I bought I
borrowed
offer for Samba day I bought the house I
gave them a fixed interest now I'm
buying houses I haven't got the time
I bought twenty nine I was involved in
twenty nine property purchases just this
year alone in 2019 and a lot of them
have been joint venture deals because I
haven't got the time to go find the
properties and negotiate them anymore
because I'm so busy so I will give a
percentage of the profit to my students
they find the deals I mean I'm still
debating today so what I want you guys
to do instead of messaging me with all
the reasons that you can't succeed in
property just just fight find people who
can help you out and marry up together
that's what business is business is
coming together with people
collaborating and off the back of the
video I just did with Patricia it was a
collaboration video that's what I do in
business all the time collaborate with
people so that's what I wouldn't say in
this video if you can find deals but you
haven't got the money how's about
package deals sell them on to investors
and charge a fee and that's called a
joint venture how about raise the
finance give a fixed fixed fee if you
can't do that because you don't got the
knowledge falling someone's got the
knowledge you put the money in just
joint venture joint venture joint
venture and if you want to joint venture
then what you need to think is you can
start thinking about what you have got
instead of what you haven't got Boxing
Day 26th of December you'll see me going
out in London with no money in central
London with the plan to get a property
for free because you can do this even if
you have no money you just hit the
knowledge so you want to get the
knowledge keep watching more videos
subscribe turn the notification bell on
anyway we're gonna go and enjoy some
more Singapore sightseeing and I see you
guys soon thanks so much if you like the
video go ahead and subscribe right now
you can do it yeah go go go
I Love You Man